[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Saucon and as you know
we like making the complicated relatable
and so here we are sitting down with dr.
Melanie Mathieu thanks for coming on the
show yeah thanks for having me yeah
definitely and Melanie is the CEO and
founder of prelate biologics and we're
going to be diving into understanding
how to print organs and tissues and
beyond right yeah yeah so you have a
good background because you got a PhD in
physiology and biophysics at Irvine and
then you were messing around with this
technology and you were like why is it
not being used for 3d printing exactly
exactly and now you were showing me
these crazy videos which will will show
you soon of you actually printing
vascular architecture and I mean like 5
to 10 microns thick right right five to
ten microns in diameter diameter right
yeah this is mind-blowing stuff this is
tiny stuff it's so small that a single
red blood cell has to go through a
single file one single file red blood
cells yeah oh my goodness those are some
all the veins that's small vasculature
yeah it's the smallest fast to turn our
body ah okay but without it none of the
organs or tissues that keep us alive can
function yep yeah because you need to
have tiny tiny cell walls and the
single-file movement of the red blood
cells to effectively distribute oxygen
and then to also carry away the waste
yep yeah yeah and that's the role of the
red blood cell that's the role of red
blood cell and the tiny tiny micro
vasculature that ferries these red blood
cells around the tissue and so normally
we're going inhale and
red blood cells carrying oxygen to
different parts of body and then red
blood cells on the way out
carrying waste waste product co2 writes
in co2 out and then they get into this
single-file line in the thinnest of the
vein exactly its thinnest diameter and
so then the complexity is like how do
you print that's small of resolution and
that's been this problem for a long it's
been a problem for a long time and a lot
of the lithography methods that are out
there it can do it but they do
lithography kind of kind of the way a
silicon chip is built so you can think
of it that way and so a lot of so it's a
light based deposition of material or
other other methods are out there but
usually there's a photoresist in a mask
but this lithography is typically done
but a resister mask or a scanning line
of a laser which is how we imaged and
that was the technology I used that's
all too slow to build complex
vasculature and tissues it would take
months two years to build anything
functional anything that's say a
centimeter cubed would take several
weeks if not years to build at the
resolution we need to be creating this
micro vasculature that functions and
brings oxygen to the tissues so compared
to what you're teaching your earlier
yeah months is just crazy in comparison
right no one's gonna wait years or
months upon themselves can't wait months
upon months right but no one's gonna
wait years and years for a kidney they
do on the donor waitlist
but we can't build something that slowly
in the lab and have it actually still
work so what we've done is we've sped up
this process significantly by taking
that laser projecting it in three
dimensions and depositing structure kind
of like Lego blocks and so we don't have
to wait for the beam to scan around we
can deposit it all at once and build the
tissue very quickly that way let's pull
this up all right
this is so video yeah and help the
visuals help and we all we all kind of
intuitively understand what
microvasculature is anyone can take
their fingers and press them together
and you watch them go from pink or to
white and then you pull them apart and
they go pink again and that those are
capillaries that's reperfusion of
capillaries so they're really in every
tissue in our body okay so as I press my
fingers together kind of squeezes all
the planet out of the canoe and wheezing
the blood out of the capillaries that's
why it turns white and then you let go
and the blood flows the blood flows back
yeah yeah yeah yeah those those examples
are so fun because they're silver
because everyone carries it around them
carries all right you can just do this
and go oh yeah okay there yeah yeah and
that's why when you tie something really
tight yeah I like it when you're kidding
me like why is it white yeah so and so
do they get that thin down to 5 to 10
microns is that but like where every
tissue in the body and the farthest
space you'll ever find them in the body
is only 200 to 300 microns apart because
that's the limit of diffusion for oxygen
so our whole body every 200 to 300
micron micrometers apart at a minimum
has a capillary in our heart because
it's constantly beating it's really
metabolically active there are only 20
microns apart so that's an even tougher
engineering problem so you you're having
an engineer 5 to 10 micron diameter of
veins about 20 microns away from each
other yeah and that's the only way to
make an actual heart right it's a
metabolically active cardiac tissue that
is mimicked to the human heart
exactly versus engineered in a well how
can we design a better right yeah yeah
what's is this video good one to start
with yeah sure that's great this one so
this is kind of an overview of how we do
our printing process so projection of
laser deposition of the vasculature
system
and then we rinse out the first layer
and we can start layering in cells on
top of that and around the vasculature
system that's already printed so this is
a kidney
that's the kidney and and so let's let's
start by let's start let's start like
let's start here so this is a this a
proprietary machine right that you guys
made it because I designed and
hand-built yep design and hand-built and
you know team of eight people that yeah
figured out how to really make this out
and so yeah i've got i've got three
optical engineers we optical engineers
and so then that's kind of this that's
this top part here so we're looking at
right up you're looking at one part of
it it takes up a whole table right now a
tape like yeah about double this size
the laser the laser and all the free
space optics we keep it open so we can
play with things and fiddle it around oh
yeah we can probably get it to about
this size or smaller yeah yeah and so
and so then the three optical engineers
are working on this upper part and so
this this upper part is how how what
what is going on with the light and then
and then it's you know it looks like
it's going into like a con like a
concave shape yeah so that that may be
more of an artist rendering there but oh
but really it's coming down it's nice
tree
yeah very much straight okay yeah but
right so what's going on to get it that
way yeah so we take a we started the
single laser beam it's probably about
two millimeters in diameter I think it's
our beam diameter somewhere around there
we expand it out so we take something
called a beam expander and we just make
a column of light that column of light
hits something that acts like a
projector it's called a spatial light
modulator you can be thought of almost
as an LCD projector type and it has
basically its liquid crystal based but
if you want to think about it in a very
easy way it has on/off switches like
little on/off mirrors that direct the
light and so you can turn each pixel off
and on and get an image out of that
right and so we take that light bounced
it off some spatial light modulator x'
we do something called phase modulation
which takes a little image that we have
an X Y and distributes it in Z and
that's how we get the hologram projected
and so then we send that in you're
turning on and off yep and then you're
in a Z plane yes and then we do some
phase modulation and get in Z plane and
then we bounce it through some more
proprietary systems that our engineers
have built and send it down through what
essentially looks like a microscope head
right now
it concentrates the light it
concentrates this little picture and on
the other end we get the full image
printed and then is that is is what you
initially can is did you put the CAD
rendering in through the late through
the laser yes so we start with a CAD
image so you know you could take an
image of this Cup right have a CAD file
of it we run it through our hologram
algorithms and those are not proprietary
they've been published I think since the
seventies but we read them through some
small hologram creating algorithms and
then run it through that system and then
it's projected got it as a hologram okay
and then as the laser comes directly
down mm-hmm then the light hits the
material right and now what is the
material so the material is right now
it's a mixture of PEG dye acrylate
polyethylene glycol it's fda-approved
once it's solidified and some proteins
things like collagen and stuff that's
natural to our body and so things that
cells are typically happy in is what
we're printing with and so we can do we
can do this process with cells present
and have them survive it and have them
grow and then though once the laser hits
the peg and collagen
then what a curse form yes so it's a
photo cross-linking event so anything
that you've let me think about it's kind
of like you can think about an epoxy
curing but it needs light to cure and so
it's a great example if you're a woman
and you've ever gotten a gel manicure I
told this to a group of like women
business leaders and they were cracking
up I'm like this is the perfect audience
okay you all get it but any sort of
light based solidification that's that's
the same reaction that we're using and
so we have a specific wavelength that
interacts with a electron donor or
something that absorbs that light kicks
off an electron and causes the
cross-linking reaction to occur very
locally and so that's how it works so
it's a light based polymerization
reaction and that's kind of where we get
the building life with lights oh yeah
life with a light yeah a light based
polymerase is just the reaction yep in
3d and with that we can get down to such
a small resolution that we can actually
build the blood vessels the capillaries
that v tissue and no one's been able to
do that fast enough to build functional
tissue before building life with light
yep
that's so cool that's our tagline yeah
yeah it took a few meetings to get there
but we've got some great creative
exalted one yeah yeah okay and then so
so as the laser comes down and hits so
then the material itself is only about
the 5 to 10 micron stick itself is where
the material yeah so so that's we can
print something that's 5 to 10 microns
diameter our actual resolutions about
half a micron and the X&Y is about 500
nanometers and in the Z it's a little
longer of a resolution it's about 3
microns but that's just because of our
optics and the way physics works that
resolution however is only dependent on
our optical system so we could go lower
in resolution and we can go higher in
resolution or yeah higher and resolution
down to about a hundred nanometers we
just kind of don't need to for what
we're printing so that's
the Swedes thought that we chose and so
then as the first sort of initial you're
right now you're at the premises we're
not we're not a bad state no no we're
not at that stage we're darn close
getting there we're getting there yeah
so to print something the size of a
kidney all at once we need to step out
of the realm of off-the-shelf optics
it's totally feasible but we'll be
requesting some custom large-scale
optics it'll probably be a little more
expensive but we're really close to
being able to do that there's no
physical limitations around doing it
because okay you're telling me that it
only takes a couple milliseconds to
print the first yeah so so depending on
the size and the optics that are
printing we have clock tower
polymerization reaction at under five
milliseconds and so we can as long as
we're depositing the light and
distributing it properly it's it's only
got our order of seconds over an order
of seconds versus the months say you're
talking right just scan it around yeah
that's just that's crazy yeah we got
these types of innovations are the ones
that we like thirst for to accelerate
science and engineering and thank you
yes okay so so we're not quite to this
part yet so so right now okay so right
now after you print off the is there
another good yeah that we should yeah so
there's one of kind of a fun vascular
structure that's a good one this one
yeah
so these print videos are not sped up at
all these are real-time just so everyone
knows and this is I think that field of
view I think heard about two hundred and
fifty microns long and my gosh about ten
microns and with their and so that's
just a natural vasculature bed that we
kind of doodle doubt ourselves to mimic
some stuff we'd seen in an article we
can take that image recreate that last
go to bed in just a few seconds so this
is
this is this is exactly what it looks
like what I mean within us this is about
five to ten microns this is about five
ten and then across the whole things you
said about to 250 microns or so yeah and
so this is the slow this is a this is
real time
yeah this is real time and it's boom
that's it
there's our structure yeah Wow holy crap
so it's actually an advancement in
manufacturing if you want to think about
it that way but the problem that seemed
the most relevant and applicable to me
as a physiologist was really getting
human tissue and real solutions out to
people and so so this is our first
application and the the kind of like the
shine that occurs as it goes that's the
that's the part of the polymerase
reaction yeah that was the first word
than that polymerization reaction the
first photo folded polymerase reaction
yeah because the electron is you're
kicking off an election detail yeah yeah
uh-huh
and that's what's causing the formal
form yes before the binding of the -
exactly yeah
atoms that form the shell that formed
this exterior yeah form them huh okay
now you're getting a chemical linkage
that's terminal linkages permanent yeah
yeah from Oh from a liquid to a salt
exactly so we're printing this all in a
liquid bath that reacts to a specific
wavelength of light and what we're doing
is sending that wavelength in in a
pattern and so it leaves that pattern
behind when we turn off light yeah
Lawrence
hey Lawrence thanks for tuning in I we
appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts on the
video if you got another comment send it
over thanks Ron it's always nice when
people chime in online yeah it's fun
it's really fun it's also cool from yeah
South Africa we had it we had a quote
from Levi shoutout to
by from Melbourne in Australia
fourteen-year-old messaged us like I
love your channel like I can't believe I
miss like that's fantastic yeah so so
it's like it's just so great we got some
at Australia since our cut it's good
it's good that people are tuning in from
across the world yeah
one of our things is that we care so
much about youth and young people tuning
it as well to get them inspired to build
the future for sure yeah and then like
and then now you're on here talking
about let's Alyssa let's keep getting
into this printing organs and tissue so
so okay so now that was that was the
full speed what camera was that I don't
know I don't know what camera we used it
was I think it was an off the shelf like
Nikon we picked up off eBay if you're
young and doing a start-up eBay's great
[Laughter]
yeah nothing no fancy camera there
that's really just the light
illumination and we have well we have we
have a microscope objective underneath
and so so we're watching the light come
through but it's hooked up to a normal
video just a normal like that's all our
base camera is there now before we keep
going this thank you is there another
sure yeah I mean let's see I think you
like the one we're printing this all
encapsulation device right yeah that was
in the other email yeah I've nosing the
other email yeah so again this is cool
selling obsolete device okay well yeah
so we can use this to encapsulate two to
three thousand cells it may be useful
and diseases where you want encapsulated
cells such as diabetes you can protect
them from the immune system or just make
them better for transplant and so that's
one without cells present but we return
routinely print these around human
insulin producing cells and we're
testing those in the lab right now as we
speak we have an active project with
that and so the cells are alive they
maintain insulin production
and we're looking at bringing that into
animal studies really soon and this is
real time that's right yeah so that's
real time so that's as fast so you want
to get that in Attica and you're
printing you see you're printing this is
this keep it two thousand cells two to
three thousand cells will fit in that
structure and that's microns that's
about 200 microns across and about 250
tall 50 tall and then so then you put
two thousand cells in there and then
that encapsulates those cells and then
it enables you to run tests within those
environments for he said for diabetes
exactly one yeah and then what's the
difference between doing it here versus
doing it like in vitro or something like
why oh why here oh why would we do it in
this yeah so this environment it's easy
for us to do things like grow stem cells
in the lab we have a collaboration where
they grow IPS pluripotent stem cells
give them all the signals to become
insulin producing cells and then they
can send them to us and we can
encapsulate them and so if we have an
active project doing that and so in an
in vitro environment it's easier to just
control what cell types you're getting
you know do all the tests to make sure
that you're transplanting what you
believe you are transplanting and yeah
so the lab environment can be controlled
in a way that makes everything safer
it's not sure if I answered your
question
[Laughter]
yeah sure this is in bonuses for brand
brand-new I mean when was the last time
somebody was like oh I can print you a
container for two thousand various cells
and you can do whatever you want with it
right test with it yeah yeah because now
you can have you know if you're printing
these fast are you already selling this
and selling the good good question and
so we're starting with building tumors
small tumors from patients so you can
test drug reactions within those tumors
and so this is so it's like oh it's like
like a two-week-old organoids there are
little mini organs
yeah because they kind of function like
right like straight up like a straight
up organ
yes I'd the body they're trying to like
yum yum eat up as much as possible and
and convince the body that is normal
yeah so so so when you're printing are
you are you taking something that looks
like the tumor inside of me and then
you're making that to test and outside
yeah that's the idea
and with our technology unlike a lot of
other tumor technologies we believe that
we can because because there are people
are growing tumor cells in little
spheroids and in collagen capsules but
the way that we do this we believe that
we can maintain a patient's immune
system or the native immune system that
is associated with the tumor and do that
so we so that we might begin to some
proprietary areas but but essentially
our encapsulation technology doesn't
care what cell type is there and it's
tunable so that we can build an
extracellular matrix that supports those
immune cells we can we can really add
anything we want to this formulation to
a certain degree and maintain our print
speeds and so so we can tune this to
look like a native human tumor
environment for the cells and that
should support our immune system just
fine so as we know tumor immunotherapy
and a lot of the ways that you work with
the immune system to recognize the tumor
as being foreign and rejected depends on
activating the immune system there isn't
really a good surrogate outside of
animal studies that allows you to test
human tumors in their native environment
and so we'd be providing a streamlined
way to do that yeah yep a streamlined
way to test tumors outside in their in
their environment but not in the body
that's exactly right
and we can build them with vasculature
we can build them without vasculature we
can introduce areas of hypoxia where
they're not getting a lot of oxygen
that's a tricky yeah that's interesting
problem into morena therapy right yeah
because then hypoxia so then if you're
introducing hypoxia then you're you're
able to run the tumor under different
circumstances and test to see if maybe
some hypoxia could work inside the
vessel well
exactly right interesting so that's the
first cell yeah so we have an active
partnership doing that right now with
another company and investigating that
so we've got a pilot project and it's
looking good so far
and that's like you're planting a couple
of these tumor casings per like day or
oh no so that was that was this took
what did that take I think seven seconds
or so to print one of those yeah and so
our structures are similar to the one
that you just played on the screen but
they can print a little bit faster and
we're working on distributing the light
in parallel and so we'd be printing
anywhere from twenty five to a hundred
at once yeah and so this is why you're
late sure we did in parallel right oh
that's so interesting yeah so we can
take one of those structures and print a
hundred at once it's our goal and rather
than going a hundred lasers as well
you're in taking one laser and just try
and break up that one leisure into the
hundred different same copy yeah and so
we're already doing that with our single
cell encapsulation and it works okay but
now that means like 25 or 100 per every
like 10 seconds and then that means like
thousands thousands per day yeah okay
and then are you able to run with that
flow right now like you can you're
getting a thousand a day there's
somebody we're not we're not quite at a
hundred a second or every 10 seconds yet
and that's really dependent again on the
optics in the laser power yeah and so
our next step was we placed an order for
a really nice custom basically printhead
you could think of it as a 3d print head
but it's a large objective microscope
objective which the right organization
the right settings to keep our
resolution the same
but increase I revealed a few and so
first we increase the field of view and
then we need to match that with some
laser power so every time you break up
the laser into let's say 100 you have a
drop in power right so in order to get
the same printing to occur you need to
up the laser power and so we have that
installed and we are yeah we're just
waiting on the custom objective you're
making awesome we have a really nimble
team I love it
yeah that's crucial because you now
you're making advancements in hardware
you're making advancements in software
making advancements in what what exact
products you're making for different
sectors that are important so you're
like yeah you're really augmenting the
project you have some interns coming in
from state yeah yeah we've got Stanford
interns true ventures who funded us this
has a really great intern program yeah
and so we got a couple interns from them
and then a really ambitious girl from UC
Berkeley is coming in and yeah it's just
a good good team yeah and so you're
gonna be up to 12 men total I'm to about
12 over summer yep and sometimes this
having a good time fighting people I
hope anyone tuning in that likes biotech
and that is really passionate about our
optics optics yeah yeah we've got yeah
so our we're doing something really fun
we're combining physiology biophysics
optical engineering computer science
there's a lot of code that's being
written to do all this faster we're
introducing some computer vision so we
can select different populations of
cells and groups and be intelligent
about the way we do that as we print and
then mechanical engineering really so
once we have 10,000 or 20,000 of these
tumor organized how do you recover them
right how do you do that efficiently in
a way that's a true manufacturing
process so so everything from biology to
mechanical engineering we've we've got
it and we've got this really nice
diverse team of PhDs that are excited by
these problems and we we move quickly
I love the fusion of all the duds five
chemistry to chemistry in there yeah
seeing some blockchain source right yeah
so I've got to figure out now how to add
blockchain and have all of our servers
mine Bitcoin when they're not running
Holograms okay so that's actually our
business model now before I ask a couple
of the questions is there another C I
think you know this really show a lot of
what we do yeah cool
yeah all right so then what I want to
what I want to ask now is we did we did
a good amount of understanding kind of
like where you're at and how it's how
it's working out right now and how like
multidisciplinary it is to actually put
it together and make it work and where
it's actually being used right now and
and how that's happening how many years
would you say you're out from the kidney
uh how many years out so I get this
question a lot and people would love to
hear that it's just around the corner I
will say with definitive confidence that
we are closer than we've ever been in
human history because solving a
microvascular problem is critical for
building a kidney
not only does it supply the kidney with
oxygen but our entire filtration system
is based on capillaries there are about
12 miles of capillaries in the human
kidney just one kidney and so the fact
that we couldn't ever build those before
was prohibitive right we could kind of
maybe build mechanical filtration
systems that was outside the body maybe
some you'd implant but those have their
own inherent problems building a real
human kidney and I would love it if we
can keep the speed and the efficiency
that our team is working out right now
and build it and I would say three to
five years that sounds right around the
corner we're close yeah and the nice
thing about a kidney is you don't need
to have a full human kidney to get
someone off style
you how do you get someone off dialysis
what do you need they need about 20% 10
to 20% are the numbers the range it's
not well agreed upon when I've talked to
the specialist but that's about the
range of kidney function you do need to
get someone off dialysis our kidneys if
you kind of make a fist that's about the
size of your kidney it's also about that
size yeah so you've got two of those
maybe a little a little bigger five
right someone's I'm up five actually can
these are an interesting organ again the
numbers aren't well well recorded but
somewhere in like 10 percent to 5
percent of people have abnormal kidneys
or a third kidney we really interesting
yeah you're not pulling my leg no have
you shaved keys well don't quote me on
that number is around that's around
there yeah some people have these
u-shaped kidneys that are joined in the
middle and they never yeah they never
know until they get a cat scan or a full
body scan
yeah cuz it the kidneys function
normally that way mm-hmm and it's a
great transplant target yes rock if you
need a volunteer I got my Uncle Joe on
kidney dialysis he'd be more than happy
to step up to the plate and test out
your I knew I immediately thought about
Uncle Joe and she said dialysis Joe it's
there so there's such a huge need for
this is fascinating over well over
600,000 people are our on dialysis have
catastrophic kidney failing us the
dialysis is a part time job it is a part
fasting yes yeah she said that he was
Uncle Joe's going in twice a day or once
a day for for two hours I think it was
three times a week
I think three times a week sounds about
right for a couple hours though right
now like it's a three so that's like
part two that's like eight hours it's a
part-time job and then and then a lot of
patients on dialysis report being
exhausted afterwards it really just it
takes a lot out of you physically
because it's not it's not our natural
process you just lose a lot of energy
out of it okay now walk us through what
it would be like to you'll need if you
only needed 10 to 20 percent of
an actual kid yeah to replace a kidney
that needs dialysis right right so what
does that look like to do the whole like
replacement process uh yeah so kidney
I'm not a transplant expert so I'm a I'm
a miss speaker why I need to be one yeah
yeah we we've got a great we've got a
great transplant consultant who's signed
up as an advisor so maybe I'll check
with the next slide before I come on
fine but as far as I as I understand it
you don't remove the diseased or
non-functional kidney but you kind of
graft in the new kidney underneath into
the blood supply and so it's actually a
very straightforward transplant surgery
it was the first transplant surgery ever
done was a twin to twin kidney
replacement and I again I should have
checked some numbers I believe it was in
the 50s okay I think yeah it was quite a
while ago and it was the first
successful example of an organ solid
organ transplant and we're where we are
it's amazing
97% of people who get a kidney
transplant five years later that's build
a functional kidney it's a great
transplant seven years though is that
what I understand that yeah my god my at
Moraine has got a kidney fry you know
it's really interesting it depends on
the transplant it depends on the health
of the original kidney going in it
depends on the person's immune system I
there's a person at UCSF who I think got
a kidney transplant from his mother and
30 years later it's still so going
strong so it's it's really dependent on
a few other factors we hope that if we
can use a person's own cells or a
perfectly matched donor imagined donors
not having to give up a whole kidney but
a sample of tissue yeah right yeah and
we can grow those cells a lot of donors
then yeah everyone's a donor that then
yeah it's really easy you know you just
you know a patch of skin or a small
biopsy yeah if you're a perfectly
matched donor you can give someone their
lives back without you know giving up
one of your own organ
yeah so the idea there is hopefully if
we're using either a perfectly matched
donor or someone's own cells that the
kidney will engraft
and be healthier that you won't have to
be on really powerful immunosuppressants
which have their own set of side effects
and yeah yeah hopefully okay this is
this is exciting is that is is that the
first market then for for you guys is
Azure now you're doing this you're doing
this tumor tumors tumors of the body
what what else that would be our first
market we approach where we'll really
have to have deep and long discussions
with the FDA yeah right and important
discussions because we love this little
test lots of clinical tests we want to
do this right the good thing is is that
it's such a well known surgery that if
we put a kidney in and it doesn't quite
work you know but we built everything
else sufficiently some of the years now
of figuring it out right so yeah yeah so
this is it being like the brand-new yeah
we don't have to reinvent the wheel in
terms of how the transplant would work
as long as we have everything else done
correctly yeah that's that's a really
important part of it okay all right so
okay so how does before and before I get
into this I just want I want to ask
about this question because I saw you
wrote it as one of the as one of the key
things which is biocompatibility mm-hm
and how do how do we ensure
biocompatibility through this process ah
very very good question so when I talk
about what it takes to manufacture or 3d
print an organ I talk about the
resolution to build the capillaries the
complexity we want to be able to match
the complexity of a human organ the
speed of course because we need to have
cells be alive still we need the patient
to still be alive by the time we're done
printing and then biocompatibility the
1u disaster bells really critical so we
want to be building organs and tissues
are biocompatible obviously non-toxic
the cells because we need the cells to
grow around them and create their own
functional environment the way that
we're approaching that currently well in
the printing process we use a non-toxic
printing process we have far red laser
light that doesn't cause a lot of DNA
damage doesn't cause any as far as we
can tell to the cells and we use that
light to build with cells present and so
the printing process itself is
biocompatible we have formulations that
cells can live in and then
transplantation being biocompatible is
also really important so that comes down
to the materials that we're using a lot
of people will have stents implanted
cardiac valves implanted other things
that are biocompatible for years and so
we're using materials like that in
combination with proteins that are
naturally found in the cells or in the
cellular environment so collagen
hyaluronic acid fibronectin the last
since all of those are components of an
extracellular matrix that help make
cells kind of happy and once you've got
that down cells are really good just
throw disco parties no I mean of course
you can do they care maybe we should try
that yeah I mean we give them the
nutrients right that they need in the
oxygen but once you get cell in an
environment where it's happy and it's
functional it's interacting with other
cells properly they start to do
something really cool which is they
produce their own extracellular matrix
and they will remodel tissues as they go
and so you know we all feel really solid
like nothing's happening but the skin on
you today isn't the skin that was there
ten years ago this has been remodeled
developed stem cells have come in
they've divided and so creating the
right environment for that to happen
really and giving the right physiologic
cues will really help build a functional
tissue and we hope to be at that stage
prior to transplant so we can really say
okay these cells have taken off they've
done the right thing they differentiate
it properly we can test that you know
biopsy the kidney that we have in lab
make sure it matches a human kidney
and then go from there so that would be
the production side of being
biocompatible this is not only the
materials that are using and then the
laser and how it's affecting the
materials and making sure that that is
able to work with actual cells but then
once it also gets put into the body can
the cells actually grow around it and
and have it become one with the body
right how long will it last before any
degrading if ever will there be
degrading right have the body recognizes
his own tissue yeah and now as
recognizes own tissue trick the body
into yeah yeah yeah lots of lots of lots
of trial and error and testing into yeah
make sure that it sticks around and that
it becomes part of the body yeah well we
can do this in animals already we know
that and and if you think about it
George church is done George church is
doing some work in that area absolutely
and if you think about it it's not very
different than let's say someone you
know is burned on the shoulder it's not
very different than the plastic surgeon
taking some skin from their leg and
transplanting it to their shoulder right
so if you use the same cells from that
patient you just happen to go out in a
different environment but they look the
same they act the same they talk to each
other the same way transplanting it back
onto the shoulder should be you know
pretty much the same that's our okay so
now we have a couple slightly more
difficult questions I think a little bit
all right let's get in there okay cool
we'll start digging with some of the
ways that we ask questions on our show
have to do with some of the or the rate
of the ramifications of Technology on on
our future especially regarding maybe
ethics and philosophy and things like
that so all right so so so so you know
the easy questions you know the son the
ones I was trained for there were three
pairs of the scientists go together
right especially in they said yeah
because like they really should know
I've been
learned about like the Jesuit education
system and they were they were they were
making people Polymathic as they were
leaving the justification system and I
thought that was very interesting
because like what would it be like if
what does the auditor biophysicist also
took some ethics and philosophy courses
like as they went and what if some
philosophers and ethicist took some
biophysics courses and physiology
campuses and so what would the world be
like then in a better place will soon be
faced with this as you work with someone
that's more in the transplant
understanding space I think you will
also end up working with someone that's
more in the ethics understanding space
as well because especially in biotech
and bioengineering this is this is
really relevant okay now here's the
question all right so you're one of your
main goals with paralysis is to
eradicate suffering is one of the goals
right right to give people their lives
back is that we say give people their
lives back yes and so that in itself is
like ding ding ding like one of the best
possible things you can do you know it's
not the best thing it's at eradicate
suffering give people lives back people
more time to be creative to be happy to
love families all stuff ok now this also
comes with human augmentation at the
same time right so it's like all right
now I have a kidney that is slowly
failing and I might only be 40 or 50 um
but now I want the ability to purchase a
proce biologics kidney and to feel like
I'm 18 again
ok now now that process usually comes
with the price as and you've paid a lot
of money to make this happen so now I
pay you a lot of money to purchase your
good hopefully we gets to a point where
it's only 10 tables that would be that
would be amazing even better a hundred
bucks generator I'd want to pay more for
me
so let's say that that is that ends up
being what that what we get to in like
five or even ten years let's say it's
only 10k hopefully okay
yeah so with the 10k mark it is only a
certain socioeconomic status can afford
it and then maybe at the hundred dollar
mark more socioeconomic status can
afford it how where where do you stand
on just like the ethics around
augmentations being made more read of
readily available for people of high or
so yeah that's a really really important
question especially with a lot of things
to happen in biotech right yeah because
R&D is expensive first I'll just put
this out there we're hoping that we can
match the price of procurement from a
donor kidney so that it would be no
different at the get-go from getting a
kidney donated so that's our ultimate
goal
that's our price point it's around 120
thousand Wow is the cost if you needed a
kidney someone volunteered raised their
hand and said okay the cost of getting
that kidney from that person is about
120,000 got and that doesn't include
that person's hospital stay or anything
like that that's transplant surgeon time
and whatnot fifteen minutes oh boy okay
so ethics questions good good right so
so that is our that is our goal for a
price point and at that price point we
will still be making plenty we'll still
have plenty on the table to continue to
do the Rd that we need to so right so
R&D is expensive it's tough to get drugs
out there it's tough to develop them
they often go off patent and then you
get to do generics so you know we're not
out my opinion is that we're not out to
couch anyone for any sort of development
or R&D costs we need to cover our own
costs and make them make these things as
available as possible and as you bring
this tech to the forefront it's
expensive at first it always is the
first therapies are always going to cost
more they're novel there's FDA processes
to get them approved you need to do
everything you can to make
get safe and that first small lucky
patient test group that it's successful
in you know reaps the benefits of that
and as things go offline and become
generic as you can expand manufacturing
processes all of these drive the price
down significantly and the faster we can
do that the better really for everyone
yeah so to piggyback on that question a
question that we asked on the show a lot
is it relates to a class-based
speciation as in the although the
arguments about the lower socioeconomic
status only coming up is true the top of
the socioeconomic status is growing it's
being exacerbated by technology just
super quick growth so what do you think
about a speciation regarding well
speciation regarding well they did not
prepare me for this question in college
really it really it really should be
right you want to think about the
implications of what you're doing you
know I think and of the ways of design
the way civilizations designed in
general you know so throughout history
it's been that way right the first
people to get vaccines you know we're
not in sub-saharan Africa right but
technology is great because it actually
spreads I think technology is great
because it spreads the capabilities to
bringing things like that to lower sis
you know economic and underserved
populations faster so you know if we can
build kidneys in the US and get them
overnight its Africa because we have
better technology or we can get the
exact genotype for all the potential
donors in a village and figure out who's
going to be the donor
you know that's technology at work and
we can start to move things forward and
yeah I think I think we'll be able to
get real solutions to people much faster
you know in terms of speciation you
don't usually need there are some people
who are have polycystic kidney disease
you need kidneys earlier but people
don't usually need a kidney till they're
in their 40s 50 is there 60
right so we've got some time to figure
that out for the next generation yeah we
should definitely be asking this
question mate you made the answer in the
way that you know you crafted it
relating to you yeah and so I'm glad
that you said that because we do think
it's really important to to get some
answers to these tough to these tough
questions absolutely what do you a quick
a quick answer to this one what do you
think about the United States working
together with other countries in the
world like China in terms of being able
to 3d print organs and tissues like how
will we collaborate across borders well
I think first of all I think we should
all work together because our the u.s.
is not alone in our health problems
China's not alone in their health
problems they have an increased rate of
diabetes year over year that is similar
if not surpassing the increases in
diabetes in the US and that's I was
getting fat no no it's type 1 it's
autoimmune
oh it's although you know the beauty
ology of autoimmune disease is not
well-defined and it may be different in
different populations especially in
diabetes so so no one's really sure
that's one of the hardest things about
this problem is that we you know if
you're getting if you're pre-diabetic
and you're a little overweight you can
go to the gym and sort that out and you
know work through it but with type 1 it
strikes kids as young as 3 years old and
they don't know why and some some really
smart people are working on sorting that
out but this is a global problem and I
think working together it's the best way
to solve this you know I don't you know
kind of like my team comes from every
walk of life and different educational
backgrounds you know we need we need a
global population to be thinking about
these problems and really put our heads
together the faster we can get solutions
people that are real yeah the better for
everyone right and then what would be an
ideal way to inspire people to work
across borders like do you do you have
an ID do you like that geopolitical idea
about again something I didn't learn in
grad school
something very fluffy
you know I it's funny I've I did live
and work in Europe for a little while
and one thing that you learn in travel
is that people really aren't very
different we all are kind of motivated
and love the same same things and hope
for the best for our kids and our family
and our friends and and it's more I like
the idea of focusing on getting the
right key people who have that vision
into the right place and then I think
the borders start to fall away and I
think the strife and the the the issues
where we don't want to collaborate they
start to disappear because when you have
people who have true vision on what's
better in their key places and you can
talk to them and you can start to move
projects forward then then then real
solutions happen all right
let's walk you through a couple of these
ending questions these are these are
easier I think than the tough version
all right your political questions
getting into it it's good good those
those are two of our fields that are
that we talk about a lot on the show
wealth and quality in geopolitics or
globalization all right so let's jump
you into the question of what is the
most beautiful thing in the world oh all
right again I'm really so so this is
going to be from my perspective
obviously what the most beautiful thing
in the world is I love the complexity of
[Music]
biology it sounds very you know kind of
trite to say that but when you start to
think about the order of chemical
reactions that happen in our body on a
daily basis and they were and they
happen in milliseconds and even just
what's going on inside a single cell
these these complex interactions this
dance that we have to keep things alive
and functioning
it's mind-blowing it is absolutely
beautiful and mind-blowing and in a way
that you know it's fun to sit up and
look at the stars at night and say gosh
we're so small that there's even smaller
things happening that are more complex
and you know I think I
one of my friends tweeted the other day
that there are more combinations or
genes in the human genome than like
atoms that in the universe right and
that's true you know like I think it
might be easier to understand
astrophysics than to understand there
might be some unknown unknowns and 1/6
of it yeah yeah yeah there are those
unknown unknowns and then in biology as
well and but but the way that like my
friend showed me a biochemical pathways
chart he made yeah and then I've also
seen those you know this how a cell
works the chemical pathways of a cell
and how cell works right it's just so
difficult to understand you got to
really go through a problem like PhD
physiology to even be able to be like oh
like I actually can read a book and
understand what they're saying here and
so I'm happy that you said that that's a
chemistry involved there's quantum
mechanics involved in that there's
there's a ton right yeah holy cow I
think that's the complexity of that is
really beautiful you know as you said
that I was thinking about like what
would Melanie's answer have been like
five years ago or ten years ago or what
will your answer be in five years so
that's an interesting thought is to be
like what like to think about what the
most beautiful thing in the world is to
like a 15 year old to a 25 year old to
35 year old and just like seeing how it
changes over your life because we don't
even like we don't quantify those
answers frequently no we don't so 10
years ago I think it would have been the
same I was getting my PhD I was working
through these problems I was thinking
about them on a daily basis I'd already
gotten a degree in biochemistry as I've
been studying this and yeah but you know
as a child I think I was fascinated by
nature and that's what really set me
down this path
like like why does this one plant grow
this way and why does this animal do
this thing and you know it's it's kind
of informed this lifelong passion of
like how do things work really in our
universe in our world yeah I'm so happy
that you had that inspiration like how
do we bring that inspiration to more
kids across the world you know paying
attention paying attention yeah and
having parents in curiosity point in the
in those directions as well curiosity
follow your curiosity is right yeah what
do you think Ronnie I want I want to see
a picture when she was a little kid tree
and like some bug no I think I probably
I would like catch things outdoors and
like bring him in my mom would be like
what are you doing with that in the
house understanding how it works mom
right like you're doing beautiful things
thank you
we need you you know keep up the good
work that's like that's like the
secondary tagline of simulation keep up
the good work I like that now okay next
question okay
are we alone in the cosmos ooh wow I
mean I think the smart answer is no but
how you define alone that's a different
question right so what's your definition
of that I mean you know there's there
could be a carbon-based life form there
could be a silicon-based life-form we
don't know right so um I think you know
a lot of unknown unknowns in the cosmos
right and really exciting research and
thoughts are happening around that do
you think there are civilizations that
are advanced that exists in the cosmos
oh I try to remember this someone
someone had a really great math equation
around this and I can't the Drake
Equation Drake Equation that's right and
I'm trying to remember what the result
was cuz I would be the one out of every
five stars five has a habitable plan has
a habitable planet so an advanced
civilization you know I don't think we
should rule it out are they interested
in talking to us who knows but yeah it's
and then you know you get into other
engineering problems right cuz physics
is gonna be the same no matter who's
advanced civilization you're talking to
so do they have the power to come say
hello
do they want to come say hello are they
motivated even to think that way by
their society who knows right so would
the physics change depending on the
gravitational pull on the planet I mean
the BIOS the biophysics would be
different would be different rules the
rules of physics are defined but the
biophysics would be impacted by the
gravitational pull on the plane and the
size of it the proximity to the star
right right interesting so that's a
that's a really important point that the
biophysics change yeah okay all right
and now our last question sure which is
do you think that we're in a computer
simulation oh no I would I prefer oh hi
the dress the dress effect we talked
about er look at how many Melanie's are
there very few of me there's no digital
copies or so many that was a cheap way
to fund my startup made copies of myself
it'll be great it'll be great yeah
there's so many will be running around
working you know no I don't you know how
you how you decide that you're not in
that really has to come down to what you
believe is real in your own perception
right so I think the human mind is very
good at convincing ourselves of things
we can also you know or the point now
where we're starting to make very very
convincing computer simulations and you
know if we happen to be in one
thanks I'm really happy I enjoy my life
as it is but you know I don't I don't
spend too much time worrying about that
honestly do you find it to be a question
that can expand the mind to new
dimensions of thought oh absolutely
right so so those kind of questions are
really fun right like our real own in
the universe are we a computer
simulation you know can we build us all
from scratch with just the right enzymes
and and cocktail of of DNA and you know
it's it's really fun because you're
pushing the boundaries of our
assumptions right in daily life and how
we approach the universe and may make us
if we stop and think about questions
like that we start to think about the
world in a different way and perhaps
make better decisions around certain
things right so those are great
questions yeah glad that you've been
enjoying these the last couple of
questions on yes oh yeah they're fun and
like you said I wasn't you know wasn't
trained about that that's that's another
thing that we do on the show is we we
bring brilliant people into other fields
of thought that they that they might not
think so much about right because if we
can bring these brilliant scientists or
entrepreneurs or educators technologists
whoever us here on the show into a
little bit of a deeper nuanced
understanding of ethics or philosophy or
politics right all these different
fields of motion and feeling like
scientists understanding emotion and
feeling is really important for
communicating their message absolutely
so so this is this is kind of a
multidisciplinary like pot of simulation
that we're stirring them know that's
wonderful and we are not selected for
our ability to communicate as scientists
like we speak an entirely different
language yes you do to each other right
but then you communicate well to you
know to audiences but then when you go
back and talk to the optics
oh it's totally different yeah yeah yeah
so it's a you know we're not selected
for that and it's important to remember
that as scientists we need to cultivate
those communication and message
presenting skills to people who don't
speak our language because otherwise no
one's going to care about what we're
doing and vice versa it's important for
the public to have the the relatability
of your communication is equally as
important as their inspiration to care
about this right yeah and I think it was
um neil degrasse tyson yes that every
kid is a scientist and it is so true
every family this work they're taking
apart things and their parents like stop
and then but cultivating that curiosity
is critical to understanding our natural
world play is a form of learning and we
need to appreciate that and encourage it
and give kids you know things to take
apart and problems that are tough that
they have to think about for a couple
days and and that that cultivates the
natural scientists and curiosity in
everyone and I think that's just really
important yeah and then also as Neil
deGrasse Tyson says actually having the
basic needs met for you so that you have
enough time to be curious to be curious
yeah
otherwise you're too busy trying to make
money to pay for rent and food and
electricity I don't have enough time to
contemplate the cosmos yeah it's a
constant exploration of curiosity yeah
what a great way to end the show this
has been such a pleasure oh my pleasure
thank you for coming on to the show
thank you so much yeah we've learned so
much art good good let's let's um let's
keep making this happen for more amazing
people in your network that are
impactors and also Wow our minds
expanded to the dimension of 3d printing
organs and tissues 3d printing true
through not layer by layer but a 3d
structure all at once all at once and
structure all at once and especially at
the microvasculature level I mean that's
really small five to ten microns
all at once not layer by layer and then
furthermore in hopefully it half a
decade we can get two kidneys yeah that
would go fantastic and eradicate more
suffering and in groper Ellis biologics
let's see what else
after kidneys where else nothing else
our going where else we're going so
thank you going on the show I want to
thank everyone for tuning in thank you
so much if you guys had a good time make
sure to take the content and go share it
with other people continue the
conversation outside of here you know as
we always say don't just consume but go
create with the content so going right
about it make a video about it talk to
other people about it maybe you'll start
your own biotech or optics company or
organ printing company with it
subscribe subscribe join the family
comment below with your thoughts and
join us on patreon we need to continue
sustaining the studio continue growing
this so we can go and bring the content
out to more people and go travel and fly
people in and do all that good stuff get
more production equipment get Ron Vargas
a paycheck every once in awhile our
producing partner and director over
there much love everyone thanks for
tuning in and we'll talk to you again
soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you